let's go next to our caller from the 6-8
to area code who's calling today from
6-8 - hi is that me
Madison um so my parents used to be like
diehard Democrats like voted for Bill
Clinton she voted for Jimmy Carter and
all that and when Obama became president
they start they stop voting Democrat I
think it has a lot to do with his race
interesting they argue that it's not but
they also started watching like Fox News
religiously like I mean it is on 24/7
and my argue like my thing is is like my
mom used to watch more like moderate
people in Fox News I don't know if you
could say there's martyrs but then she
stopped because she used to say oh
they're just lying they they don't know
Democrats are all these socialists
they're trying to take our guns all this
and then now she watches like Tucker
College spin which she used to complain
about how he was too bright ring she now
watches she just watches all these
right-wing so right and then now she
watches even like even more conservative
like news networks like American news
network so let me just back up because
this is so fascinating
so your parents were just
run-of-the-mill Democrats during the
1990s and even before during Jimmy
Carter and then they've been pulled now
here's the question and maybe you don't
know the answer to this did they start
becoming conservative because of
something else and then they sought out
the right-wing media or was it the
right-wing media that made them become
more radical I think it was it was a I
remember she started watching Fox News
was because we used to watch the view
and the incident with Bill O'Reilly
happened where he called like Muslims
killed like did 9/11 all that yeah and
my mom was like oh that she did she
didn't agree with it at the time but
she's like oh I want to see what this is
all about and by doing that she ended up
going into this rabbit hole of like
complete like like all of that and my
thing is is like I keep hearing people
like say oh well you know like if we get
it just backs out blah blah blah
it's like no because like even when I
say stuff like well you know this is
this like I was talking about justice
reform and how like a lot of people
aren't guilty but end up going to jail
and she's like that's not true and I was
like okay well the FBI said all this and
she's like that doesn't matter that's
just not true that's a lie
Wow I was like okay it no I'm at least
on social issues has your so has your
mom notably like for example was she I'm
just giving examples I'm not saying this
was she not homophobic and now she is or
was she not seemingly racist and now she
says racist things like have you seen a
change even on social stuff like that
yeah I'm like um so I mean so like
before when I was little she said I
don't care gets married blah blah blah
but then she's like I like 2016 that I
finally came out I started to change and
was like gay marriage is only between a
man and woman and nothing like that
can't happen social like racist things
she used to be like complete I mean
she's from the 60s so like a little bit
but like it wasn't as bad but now it's
just like way worse like like it's
horrible
wait did you say that when you came out
to your mom she became homophobic no it
was like she already started to like
become homophobic and then like now
she's more like well I don't care what
you do with your life but Maher just
between a man and a woman and I'm just
like okay so that means you're not going
to come to my wedding and she's like
well you know it's I just you know so I
think it's more because of Fox News and
all that so like my thing is like I hear
a lot of people saying like stuff like
oh well you know if you give them facts
it's like turn them or whatever it's
like no you're you're correct when you
say like Trump supporters will not
change like that oftentimes when you
beat people over the head with facts
they don't they get defensive and they
believe their pre-existing views even
more they don't change their mind it
seems you're saying that's what you're
experiencing with your parents yeah it's
pretty yeah and my thing is is like
people like they're like well it can't
be that bad but it's like yeah like I
believe it Donald Trump murdered
somebody on national
television my mom would say well that
person went at him right well you know
what I honor thank you Trump also agrees
that if he killed someone on Fifth
Avenue nothing would happen so it seems
that you and Trump both agree about
folks folks like that listen I'm very
sorry to hear about this it sounds
really difficult but I really appreciate
you sharing it with me and the audience
today all right all right appreciate
that call on that note we will go to a
break I I apologize everybody I was not
able to get to I know there are about 30
people currently holding I do the best I
can every week we will talk to more
folks next week